Battle Royale is not friendly the
players by design that's why people love
it
however player unknowns battlegrounds
does take the sting out of combat by
making sure that kills and deaths come
from skill and decision making and not
clunky interface design it's a cruel
world out there and we're going nose
down to bring you six things you should
know before playing battlegrounds this
game has gained a lot of traction on
Steam lately so give us a thumbs up and
subscribe if you want more coverage
number one is battle royale for you if
you haven't played this mode either as
an ARMA mod or as a standalone break off
from h1z1 called king of the hill battle
royale is a game of last person standing
around a hundred players drop out of a
cargo plane onto a map and as the
playable area on the map shrinks over
time they scavenge and fight to the
death until only one remains battle
royale is not a game about fairness or
fast responds or heavy rewards so expect
to get your enjoyment from cleaning out
houses lots of running and occasional
fast and decisive gunfights it's really
a game about the enjoyment of gameplay
number two weapon mods are meaningful
battlegrounds has an easy-to-use mod
system that I've wanted in king of the
kill for a while there was something
like this in ARMA but it was just
nowhere near as clean as it is in this
game so when you find an attachment pick
one up and click on it if it can be
equipped the mod slot on the
corresponding weapon in your inventory
will light up if you're in a hurry right
click on it and let it auto attach
itself to the closest available weapon
suppressors and a cogs are particularly
valuable and things you should focus on
first since nothing attracts attention
like shooting keeping your distance from
other players picking fights you can win
and staying relatively silent are all
keys than making it as far as you can I
can promise you that lighting off an
unsuppressed aka as great as that feels
will lure and other players
with fairly good directional audio they
won't have much trouble locating you
number three no a gun when you first
pick up a weapon hit B to cycle through
the fire modes there's nothing more
embarrassing than getting killed because
you didn't know how many bullets were
gonna come out when you pulled the
trigger also use common sense don't take
on a guy across a field with a sniper
rifle when your gun doesn't have the
reach and make sure to consistently put
types of guns in the same inventory
slots do this because gunfights are
unpredictable and you need to be able to
reach for certain weapons from muscle
memory to avoid freaking out and doing
this going back to the idea of sound
design and knowing weapons after a while
you'll be able to tell if a shot came
from a rifle afar
if so break line-of-sight and get out or
from an SMG up close get ready for a
brawl number four armor as it stands in
the current build of the game helmet
seem to have the greatest effect with a
level three helmet protecting your
noggin and face there is body armor and
the durability stat is what you should
be looking at rather than level pretty
much all body armor works the same if
you survive a gunfight see if the other
guy has more durable armor than you do
close so far are just for show
since movement attracts attention more
than clothes go nuts number five don't
leave a trail a lot of people get sloppy
and don't use the following tip close
doors behind you one of the biggest
tells that you're on a player's trail is
a series of open doors pointing right at
them do not give other players this
satisfaction
when you get better you can start
playing door games like leave the door
open and peekaboo or just punch out
parts of the door for murder holes
number 6 decide upfront if you're
playing the short or long game for the
long game find a vehicle and avoid
everyone until the very end
for the short game drop into civvies
right away and take your chances
he'll mix it up depending on your mood
that night and how much time you have to
play if you die battlegrounds does a
great job of getting you back in the
action quickly we know a lot of you are
playing battlegrounds at the moment and
we want to know what your favorite spots
are for the best guns and attachments
our tips and tricks are bound to changes
the game develops it's been a great few
months for shooter fans
we're also crazy excited to learn more
about state of decay 2 at e3 this year
so sub for all of our ongoing coverage
over the summer thanks for watching
[Music]